in turkey a slimy
floating mass of yellowish white sea
slime
is threatening marine life and the
fishing industry especially
in the sea of marmara and the waters
south of istanbul
but it's also in the black sea and the
agency the so-called cease not it
is caused by poor waste management
helped along by rising water
temperatures
due to global global warming the turkish
government recently launched an action
plan to clean up this
slimy substance many say the efforts
come too late our correspondent has
braved the waters off the sea of marmara
and sent us this report
webs of thick yellowish slime
they are covering corals wrapping
themselves around
crabs and sea urchins
suffocating marine life
but this isn't a horror movie it's under
water footage from the sea of marmara
off the coast of istanbul the so-called
sea snot
in science peak marine usage is produced
by some algae
the slime has been spreading for weeks
thriving on warm temperatures
and pollution it's a man-made
disaster
the sea snot is very difficult to grab
hold off
this stuff is so slimy it slips through
your hands
and back into the water
it's really revolting
an aerial view illustrates the extent of
the environmental crisis
carpets of mucus along the coastline
clogging ports and beaches
as well as affecting the sea of marmara
and the metropolis of istanbul
the slime has also taken over parts of
the adjoining
aegean and black seas it's a threat to
the local fishing industry
and swimming is now impossible in many
places
i had heard of the seas not but now i
can see how bad it really is
i tried swimming where there is less of
it but my skin
still felt itchy
we usually come surfing here every week
but now we are really worried
we have to go further out because the
slime is all over the shore
i've been diving here for 10 years but
i've never
seen a natural disaster like this there
was cease not when i was a child
but it was never as bad as this
the turkish government has recently
started to tackle the problem
the environment minister launched a
massive cleanup operation
dredgers are pumping out the slime and
workers are bringing the muck
ashore for disposal it looks like an
impossible task
and many experts say it's already too
late
what we see on the surface is very
worrying
but it's just the tip of the iceberg the
real problem
is under the water this is where the
slime is spreading
and it's getting worse every week
marine biologists like mustafa say the
scourge of csnot
is not just a turkish problem but a
stark warning to the world
that climate change is pushing our
planet's life support systems
to the brink
you